hello everyone my name is bradley and
this is some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online jungle now about a
year ago i made a video on how to
disappear without a trace how to
effectively erase your digital footprint
and also the crumbs that go with it
right that might help to eventually
track you down now this video was
watched by over one and a half million
people and to be honest i didn't
actually expect such a huge response but
what's more i actually stopped this
video before the most interesting part
could begin
so today i'm going to figure out how to
start a new life in a world where every
single step you take leaves a digital
footprint so vivid it may as well be
fossilized and kept in the british
museum maybe it's not too late to run
away and start all over again
i gathered all of this information from
open sources across the web and i also
verified it with some sub specialists
and yes we have them now remember please
do not take any of my advice
directly okay my aim is to effectively
explore the hypothetical and not to see
federal agencies mi6 or the tax
authorities so like i said before my
name is bradley but i think this name
will have to go i mean look at this for
instance according to the office for
national statistics 310 474 boys were
born in britain in 1998. i actually
never thought before about how my name
was so unique but that's pretty bad if i
keep it it'll be far too easy for
someone to find me and therefore let's
use the same statistics here to find
myself a more common name so in 1998
almost 10 000 boys were born who were
named jack and second and third places
were james and thomas there were about
nine and a half thousand of them and in
the top five most popular names were
also joshua and daniel there are
actually about seven thousand of them
it's at this early step that
inexperienced schemers often make a
mistake the fashion for names is
changing rapidly if you type in the most
popular names in the uk in 2021 well the
results on google be completely
different oliver george arthur noah and
muhammad will appear in the top spots
whereas in 98 none of these were popular
at all and therefore it's worth choosing
a new name that takes into account my
age based on statistics from the end of
the last century i'll select a surname
from the five most common so my name is
taylor james taylor and today i'm going
to tell you how to start a completely
new life leaving your old one behind so
let's go
now first of all do you know how much it
actually costs to change a name 42
pounds and 44 pence to be precise that's
about 50 if you're one of my us friends
and that's how much this totally legal
procedure costs and the process is
actually very simple too you just need
to fill out a small questionnaire pay
the fee and in three or four weeks
you'll be able to use your new name
legally unsurprisingly more than 85 000
britain's change their names every year
using such a practice of course in this
case it's not only the government or the
police that have access to the
information about your old name because
all entries are published on the gazette
website and they're easy to find through
a simple google search too and yet real
criminals still use this opportunity to
change names in recent years more than
900 convicted child sex offenders have
undergone name change procedures and
have subsequently been able to get jobs
in schools kindergartens and hospitals
and therefore if you have suspicions
about the people around you don't be
lazy check the history of their name on
said sources similar procedures exist in
other countries too for instance in the
united states you can legally change not
only your name but even your social
security number american law actually
makes it possible to replace your ssn in
the case of identity theft and this law
is sometimes used by scammers who put
their own data out there and then
declare theft the procedure takes longer
than in britain but ordinary people can
become completely new people through
these procedures but these of course are
just legal ways to change your name real
hardcore off-gridders go even further
let's bring out the dark web burner
computer
now on the dark web you can easily find
hundreds of ads for the sale of fake
documents i'm talking driver's licenses
passports birth certificates even fake
degrees which is something we'll talk
about later and the price of such
documents depends on the credibility of
the seller the degree of reliability and
also the country of issue of course in
this video i'm not going to transfer
money to the owners of these sites
they're all criminals right regardless
of whether they're scammers if they say
want an advanced payment and then
disappear with my money or whether
they're forgeres if they really hand
over the documents at the end of the day
but let's imagine that i was willing to
take a risk
send say a couple of thousand dollars
and i would actually receive my order
well a couple of passports in different
names driver's license and even a degree
in something like horse forensics could
quite easily be acquired so now i can
travel around the world like a real
secret agent right
unfortunately not
take a look at the cover of my british
passport we've got here you see this
little thing down here
well what do you reckon that is this
icon under the word passport it actually
means that a chip is located there that
contains a variety of different
information and the principle is similar
to the nfc chips i talked about in the
last video the chip stores all of my
personal data my biometric information
and even a digital copy of my passport
photo and this is all in encrypted form
so it's almost impossible to fake all of
this but the interesting thing here is
the only time we really face a
comprehensive passport check like this
would be at the border it's really
unlikely that your employer or say your
apartment owner will check your passport
using biometric scanners most people
don't even know these things exist and
therefore fraudsters usually travel
using real documents and it's only once
they're in the country that they begin
to use the fakes now usually because of
this the documents are bought locally
it's too dangerous to carry fake
documents in your luggage for instance
and if they're found at customs you'll
be immediately taken into custody
however there's a very big difference
here between counterfeiting and forgery
sometimes these documents are assembled
from a myriad of different parts of
different documents and sometimes
fraudsters will actually take stolen
documents and replace the photos of the
owners and here there's really no way
you can choose a random name so maybe
i'll have to become some kind of pedro
jimenez
now as a more complex alternative
fraudsters can take a blank passport and
enter the required information directly
either that which has been stolen from
real people or that which is simply
fictitious like that of james taylor and
all of this will determine the price of
a fake the more complicated and
expensive fake is the more useful it can
be for more significant activities so
let's get back to my new life
i'm not planning to commit any financial
crimes here i just want a fresh start
and therefore if i decide to move across
borders i'll use my real passport and
then and only then i'll use fakes
moreover if i decide to move somewhere
like america then instead of using one
dubious passport i'd be better off
buying a fake driving license an ssn
card and also a college diploma all in
the same name for everyday life these
documents look more authentic and
besides even a really good fake it's
unlikely to save you from a rigorous
police check and therefore i actually
won't be driving around i don't want the
attention of say traffic police the
driving license will only serve to
confirm my identity at work and also
when renting a house taking out a loan
or a mortgage won't work either i don't
want to get involved with a fake credit
history because well i don't need to
draw that extra attention to myself if i
have any problems with the law oh well
i'll have to use my real passport it's
better to have problems with an expired
visa than say accusations of document
forgery importantly i haven't actually
decided yet whether i'll move to a
different country or not but i know for
sure that i'd preferably get lost in a
big city no one will pay attention to a
new person in chicago or liverpool but
in castle rock or derby someone will
definitely be interested in the past of
a certain james taylor but in any case a
little work will have to be done on the
biography of said character now this is
where things get interesting
[Music]
in the era of the total dominance of
social media to be without a facebook or
instagram profile invites unnecessary
questions and therefore i'll have to
take care of creating a new social media
persona and first i'll sort out my
appearance i'll have to radically change
my hairstyle i mean i'll either shave my
head completely or wear wigs until my
hair grows out i might combine this with
a beard too something i've actually
never worn before this will obviously
only change my image but it will give me
the possibility to increase my age by 10
years and i'll explain why that's
important a bit later and surely you've
noticed that i tend to frequent the old
savoro suit
alas they will have to be forgotten now
i'll dress in the style of i don't know
jack reacher i'll use secondhand clothes
from army stores right army boots work
pants with a bunch of gadgets in my
pockets and under my long sleeve shirt
i'll wear weights and all of this will
eventually change my gait and overall
image i'll move slower with heavier
steps and i'll just simply look
different
alternatively i could go for maybe a
hipster image with long hair and a beard
i might lose some weight wear some baggy
shirts and necklace and maybe get a
myriad of very noticeable trendy tattoos
either will work and also in either case
i will wear glasses i'd buy a pair with
weak lenses probably around 0.5 or 0.75
because they can actually be worn by a
person with perfect vision and they
won't really cause unnecessary questions
or discomfort to the wearer now my new
image is finished i'll deal with my
facebook page and this is quite an easy
part
i won't buy a stolen profile or imitate
someone else's life on the contrary i'll
create a socially new one now i'm using
my fictitious name but i'll change it
slightly for example i'll use a shorter
form and insert a nickname so james
taylor will turn in something like jim
duke taylor and this will hide me from
those who are looking for the real james
taylor and at the same time i'll be able
to show my profile to new friends or a
realtor for the avatar i'll use a photo
in my new style but my profile picture
won't be your straightforward headshot
i'll actually take a picture of myself
against a noisy background i'll reduce
the photo to 300 dpi and i'll save it in
low quality i will of course remain
pretty recognizable to my new
acquaintances but if a photo catches the
eye of people from my past they won't
recognize me at all now these steps are
going to help to hide some of my
characteristic facial features all that
remains is to protect the photo from an
image search and to do so i'll use a
cloaking algorithm this will
imperceptibly distort my face so that
facial recognition systems won't be able
to compare it to other photos either the
first and so far the only post on the
profile will be the information that my
old profile was hacked and that i
decided to start a new one this will
explain the recent creation date of my
account as a finishing toucher i might
add some friends uh university that
according to legend i graduated from and
perhaps one or two places of previous
work
the university of course will be real
well the one that's listed in my fake
diploma but the friends and the
workplace are completely fictitious the
random users service will help me to
generate the faces of my friends and i
will create the names and logos of
employers using namelicks.com
[Music]
remember i said to you i'd choose an
image that would make me look say 10
years older will i need this so that
there are no well unnecessary questions
about my facebook profile so just like
that in the eyes of marketers i'll
belong to a completely different bracket
of marketing indeed i'll copy the habits
of stereotypical introverts at beginning
of the 2000s and i'll email more often
than i'll use messaging apps maybe i'll
reminisce openly on facebook about the
good old days and recall phrases from tv
store ads i don't know
[Music]
but any real deception here is easy to
uncover even through the most minor of
inconsistencies the more details
involved the easier it is to make a
mistake any professional detective will
confirm that this is you and therefore
well i need to draw my past with as many
long strokes as possible with the brush
i was born in a working class
neighborhood on the outskirts of london
my mother wanted me to go to university
so i had to study when she died suddenly
i gave up i tried to enlist in the army
but i wasn't accepted for health reasons
so i argued with my father and left home
i got a tefl qualification and i moved
to india hyderabad to pursue a
relationship with the beautiful daughter
of a maharaja
and i'll definitely have to work here
even if i do have a well-lined wallet
with bitcoin from my previous life it
will be very difficult to explain this
to the owner of a rented apartment your
money can and should be earned online of
course if i'm going to disappear well i
can't be a presenter on a youtube
channel anymore
that'll have to be left in the past and
in general it's not advisable to attract
more attention to yourself therefore i
wouldn't even consider a career as say a
business coach or a binary options
consultant i would generally prefer
not to meet with customers or colleagues
in person and i'd certainly prefer a
small number of tasks from different
companies to say one large project from
one company performers of small tasks
for lots of different companies attract
less attention so i need to find a
modern version of say seasonal fruit
pickers but the answer for me here is
quite obvious
copywriting now according to statistics
from the pay scale website a novice
copywriter can expect an annual income
of around 42 000
to start a modest new life that should
be enough i mean well of course i have a
rich vocabulary i have experience
writing scripts and a few marketing
tricks up my sleeve but
you know of course i won't be able to
present
some subscripts even under an elias and
well
to get an order to get my first orders i
need a portfolio and therefore i'm going
to work exclusively on my portfolio for
the first couple of months and no i'm
not going to be writing about
cryptocurrencies and it in general the
sphere of my interests will have to be
something different more straightforward
and mundane for example the power tools
market
but to form a portfolio knowledge about
cyber security will actually be useful
to me for instance the first articles
that i write let's say market reviews
life hacks comparisons well i'll just
buy them for myself and write reviews
and to do this i'll use other people's
accounts which are easy to find and
acquire on the dark net and through
these accounts i'll buy orders for
myself and of course there will be no
profit here on the contrary i'll
actually lose money on commissions but
my rating will grow on the copyrighted
exchange and this technique actually
used to be often used by new hotels on
booking sites through fake people they
booked empty rooms and then wrote good
reviews and gave high marks
booking.com and airbnb have already
learned how to deal with this but
still works on some digital platforms
for copywriters and i'm obviously going
to choose these smaller copywriting
services that you know conduct as few
checks as possible on their user base
and also those that allow say anonymous
money withdrawal and i think that in
maybe three or four months be able to
create a good reputation for myself and
get my first real orders and beyond that
well it all depends on my brain i reckon
in a couple of years i'll be able to
reach the level of say 50 to 60 000 a
year and that should be enough for a
single guy living in a big city now the
people watching this might be thinking
what if i can't write well well i would
recommend in any case looking to a
variety of different freelance
professions remember you've got that
fake diploma right
but look is all of this really worth it
i mean i thought a lot about real ways
of disappearing in preparation for this
video but in the end i realized that i
would probably never use these ideas you
can never completely get rid of your
memories i mean what drove you out of
your house in a previous life is really
likely to make an appearance again
and the life of a fugitive is pretty
lonely hiding your past from others is
also extremely difficult small mistakes
gestures hesitations all of these are
inevitable unless you're really jason
bourne here people just end up not
trusting you relationships will be
difficult in order for the legend to
last longer then it's expiry date you'd
have to communicate with other people as
little as possible it's unlikely that
you'll be able to create a new family i
mean imagine if you met the right one i
mean what are you going to introduce
yourself by
will you ever be able to tell the truth
about yourself will they even believe
you if you do
in an attempt to run away can also
result in serious monetary losses and
you will inevitably run into trouble
with the law on the dark net no one
guarantees the quality of forge
documents you're not going to be able to
submit a claim and return the purchase
in any case i mean chargeback doesn't
apply there
and what if you're caught with a fake
passport or driving license i mean the
penalty is prison in all countries over
the world buying a forged document is
effectively already a crime well my name
is bradley i mean james taylor and even
if you do disappear make sure to
reappear with a new youtube account and
subscribe to some sub once more at least
you've now got the advice needed to do
so i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you